a British photographer recently won a  big award for an incredible picture he  took check this out it shows two mice  fighting on a subway platform zoom in a  little bit really just look at this  photograph yeah it almost this is this  is real it's this beautiful photograph  that was taken they got a lot of  attention it almost looks fake but it's  a real photo of a few mice fighting  here's the more amazing part no one  knows that fight right there was just  apparently just the beginning of the  tussle they were having it apparently  escalated from there just take a look at  this footage from moments after that  photo was taken  [Applause]  [Applause]  you